Il n'y était pas retourné depuis l'âge de 15 ans...
Cyprien se rend en Roumanie...
Il y a quelques semaines je suis retourné en Roumanie, sur la terre de mes ancêtres.
J'y étais pour l'anniversaire surprise d'un pote.
Sa copine l'a emmené à Bucarest.
Quand il est arrivé dans la chambre d'hôtel, nous et tous ses potes on l'attendait pour lui faire une surprise
et pour passer un week-end mythique.
Pourquoi la Roumanie ? Bien évidemment pour
la nourriture, la culture, l'architecture.
Bref, l'alcool pas cher !
Avant toute chose, je me dois de vous avertir si un jour,
vous allez en Roumanie et que vous êtes
invités à manger chez des Roumains, faites très attention.
Ne faites pas confiance aux bouteilles en plastique
Ceci est un communiqué du ministère de la santé.
En Roumanie, ils font un alcool maison qui s'appelle la "Tuica" et qu'ils mettent
systématiquement dans des bouteilles en plastique
Evian, San Pellegrino, Cristalline, tout ce que tu veux.
Et moi dans mon enfance, j'ai toujours vu cette bouteille-là
sur la table des repas de famille
et il n'y avait que les adultes qui avaient droit d'en boire,
forcément, surtout... Mémé.
(Réaction de Mémé)
Alors la tuica comme c'est un alcool fait maison,
le taux d'alcool peut être très très très élevé
c'est pour ça que les Roumains ont l'habitude de la couper avec...
rien.
*Chanté* C'est comme ça en Roumanie !
Alors, je suis allé à Bucarest en décembre,
il faisait -16 degrés, j'ai cru que j'allais crever.
C'est un climat assez typique d'Europe de l'est où il fait
très chaud l'été et très très froid l'hiver.
- C'est ce qu'on appelle un climat continental.
- C'est un climat de merde, surtout.
- Oui on peut dire ça aussi.
Alors pendant tout le weekend la bande de potes
voulait que je parle roumain mais moi, je parle que dalle en fait.
Avec mes parents je parlais français, à la limite
je comprends les phrases que me sortait ma grand-mère.
Maintenant que j'y pense en fait, ma grand mère me parlait comme un chien
Et je sais rien dire d'autre que ces phrases là
donc autant dire que ça allait pas me servir à grand-chose à Bucarest
C'est pour qui ça ? Hein c'est pour qui ?
Allez, va chercher !
(Bruit de couvert qui tombe)
Alors on n'est pas si perdu que ça avec la langue en Roumanie déjà parce que les Roumains parlent plutôt bien anglais
et aussi, si on est pas perdu avec la langue là bas, c'est que même si la Roumanie est entourée de pays qui utilisent l'alphabet cyrillique,
avec ce genre de lettres qui viennent d'une autre dimension, la Roumanie fait exception
et utilise l'alphabet latin donc on a exactement le même alphabet que la Roumanie.
- Objection !
On a quelques différences dans notre alphabet !
- D'accord
- Tu connais la cédille ? (c'est ça -> ¸)
- Oui la petite couille sous le "ç", on connaît ouais.
- Et si on la mettait
sous le "T" !
- Non, mauvaise idée déjà parce que ça tient pas ; au moindre coup de vent la cédille tombe,
à la limite vous pouvez mettre sur le côté ça fait comme une guirlande
- Non! On la met sous le "T" !
Mais je note quand même l'idée là, le coup de la guirlande pour les fêtes ça peut être sympa !
- Si je peux aider !
Alors, le bâtiment le plus connu de Bucarest c'est le Palais du parlement
- Qui est le plus grand bâtiment administratif du monde !
- Après le Pentagone...
Oui, ben ça va ! Oui, c'est après le pentagone.
Le Palais du parlement a été construit sous l'ordre du dictateur Ceausescu,  parce que oui la Roumanie a été sous une
dictature communiste et en 1989 ils ont fait un procès au dictateur et il a été démis de ses fonctions...
c'est pas vrai ; il a été fusillé, lui et sa femme.
*Chanté* C'est comme ça en Roumanie !
Fallait pas les faire chier !
Il se retrouve donc avec cet énorme bâtiment
de 350 000 m² : c'est presque aussi grand que le Vatican sur douze étages
et le problème, bah c'est que c'est trop grand, ils essayent de mettre des trucs à l'intérieur genre le parlement, le conseil des ministres
tout ça, ils remplissent même pas 30 % du bâtiment. Il y a 70% qui est vide, paye ton lieu de travail.
J'ai reçu un mail, il faut que j'aille voir la compta. Tu sais où c'est ?
La compta ? Ouais, c'est simple c'est à droite au bout du couloir
*Musique folklorique*
*musique folklorique* La compta ?
*Musique folkorique*
*musique folklorique* Compta ?
*Beau crachas de Tuica de Cyprien*
Je le répète, ne faites pas confiance aux bouteilles en plastique.
- On a d'autres bâtiments connus genre celui-ci
je sais pas si tu connais
- Alors je veux pas te contredire je suis désolé,
mais ça c'est à Paris en fait.
- Non non, alors pas du tout ça c'est à Bucarest,
je le vois tous les jours.
- D'accord. Comment il s'appelle ?
- *accent roumain* L'arc de Triomphe
- Ah bah c'est marrant, on a le même nom.
- C'est le hasard total.
- Ouais, c'est un hasard ouais...
- Peut-être que vous avez copié ahaaa
Donc oui, ils ont l'Arc de Triomphe aussi
qui s'appelle l'Arc de Triomphe. Tout pareil.
Il y a un autre bâtiment assez connu à Bucarest
qui a été construit avec la même folie
des grandeurs que le Palais du parlement.
Et ce projet de 400 millions d'euros ne fait pas
l'unanimité dans la capitale,
on peut comprendre pourquoi.
- Salut Mikhail
- Salut Cyprien
- Là on a un projet très très lourd pour la ville.
Ok *joyeusement* ?
- Ok ouais bonne nouvelle ok
pour les habitants super vas-y balance.
- Je parle d'un projet à 400 millions d'euros mon pote
- D'accord tu m'as chauffé, continue.
- Dont 70% d'argent public.
- Ok là comme ça je pense à des autoroutes.
Des autoroutes partout, nickel.
- Ici à Bucarest, on va construire
- Des hôpitaux, des hôpitaux pour la santé c'est bien ça.
- La plus grande...
- Ecole, pour l'éducation mais oui je suis con,
des écoles derniers cris, trop bien.
- Eglise !
- Quoi ?
- Orthodoxe du monde. La plus grande église
orthodoxe de la planète ici à Bucarest.
400 millions d'euros mon pote !
Yes ! Attention c'est pas de l'eau ça.
- Je sais.
La cathédrale du Salut de la nation
aurait dû être terminée en 2017
mais finalement elle a ouvert ses portes
le week-end de notre présence, on a eu du bol
mais non, elle est toujours pas terminée en fait, à l'intérieur c'est brique et béton.
Alors grâce à ma famille je connais bien la nourriture roumaine.
Les micis, les sarmales, la tochitura, le drob.
Et mes potes me demandaient "Est-ce que c'est possible de manger autre chose que de la viande?"
Attendez les gars je crois que vous avez pas compris
le principe de la nourriture en Roumanie.
Vous avez pas remarqué autour de vous
quand même ?
- J'ai faim.
- Ah tu veux manger de la viande ?
- Non.
- Alors t'as pas faim.
- Si.
- Bah dans ce cas, tu veux manger la viande.
- Non.
- Bah tu veux manger quoi alors ?
- Bah je sais pas, des légumes.
- Des quoi ?
La viande c'est pas automatique.
Parlez-en à votre Roumain.
J'ai visité que la capitale mais
il y a plein de choses à dire sur la Roumanie.
Y'a le château qui a inspiré Dracula,
y'a les tenues traditionnelles.
Ils fabriquent le laser le plus puissant du monde.
Leurs billets sont en plastique.
C'est pas une blague hein on se voit à travers
le toucher est vraiment bizarre.
Il y a aussi leurs danses et cette tradition
bizarre qu'ils ont de casser des oeufs pour pâques.
Bref peut-être que je vous en reparlerais
si je retourne en Roumanie.
Pas pendant l'hiver,
ça c'est sûr !
Et j'aimerais juste vous quitter avec quelques images
et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner.
*Musique "Dragostea Tin Dei"  en version sentimentale*
Lâche un Like et abonne toi !
Sous-titre : T0MAT0 44, LP & Hylane Lefebvre (En Roumain) Aristide Liébé (En Français)
<3